it's not good for us when you have a
culture and music which glorifies
baby mama we have a culture problem in
black america i think the best way to
fix it is for everybody to stop debating
about it
everyone stop the hand-holding and let
black americans get to work
democratic presidential nominees have
received on average
90 of the vote from black americans for
the last six decades
these candidates have run and continued
to run on race specific handout programs
like affirmative action
and now slavery reparations to
supposedly save the black community from
racism embedded
deep within american society the work of
improving black lives has largely been
stripped from black americans by liberal
politicians and thought leaders
telling black americans they're victims
of america that is what inspired candace
owens into a political career
candace had always thought she was a
democrat that is until the media's
dishonesty during the 2016 election woke
her up
since coming out as conservative she
speaks on black culture the victimhood
promulgated within it and a society
weaponizing race for political power
in 2018 she founded blexit a movement
encouraging black and minority
communities to jump ship
from the democratic party kansas who
finds herself
frequently cancelled on twitter recently
posted a video criticizing the propping
up of george floyd as a hero
that video went viral and resulted in an
onslaught of attacks
we'll get into that controversy here
we'll also discuss candace's own
traumatic experience
of being treated as a victim by the
naacp and other organizations that
hindered
rather than helped her what cardi b's
interviewing joe biden says about the
way
democrats see the black vote and a whole
lot more
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special just a
reminder we will be doing some bonus
questions at the end with candace owens
the only way to get access to that part
of the conversation
is to become a member go over to
dailywire.com become a member you'll
have access to all of the full
conversations with every single one
of our amazing guests candace owens
thanks so much for joining the show
thanks for having me so first of all
everybody should go pick up
a copy or pre-order a copy of blackout
which comes out very shortly sure to be
an enormous best seller congratulations
on the book also congratulations on you
told me this i'm not giving anything
away
you're pregnant yeah that is an amazing
thing that is a life-changing thing
how do you feel about that i'm excited i
mean i'm really excited for that next
chapter of my life and i would say in
terms of my
political life the stakes still a bit
higher in terms of where america is
going to go
so let's start with where america is
right now we're watching as we speak
major riots in kenosha wisconsin we've
seen major rides in seattle we've seen
major rise in portland in l.a in
washington d.c
in new york city in chicago virtually
every major city all democratic governed
has broken into extraordinary levels of
rioting
and looting the media have informed us
that all of this
is apparently a good thing that this is
this is changing america in a positive
way
barack obama suggested at the dnc that
the protesters are really doing
something wonderful and the media have
conflated the protesters with the
rioters
and with the looters so i want to get
your overall opinions first of all on
the black lives matter
movement because it seems to me that
black lives matter can mean
three separate things and there's been
an attempt to conflate all of them one
the inarguable proposition that black
people matter second the idea that black
lives matter as an organization is good
which seems crazy and third
that america is systemically racist and
evil and i've
yet to see exactly how the black lives
matter movement which seems to stand for
both the organization and the idea that
america's evil how is that making
america
have you do you believe that what's
going on right now in america and has
been going on since the death of george
floyd has made america better in any way
so i mean i think i've kind of made
myself a staunch adversary or the black
lives
matter movement it is uh the antithesis
of everything that i believe in um as an
american first and foremost and
no yeah they're operating under the
guise of something that's common sense
black lives matter and and they're doing
nothing to prove or to show that black
lives matter to them because they don't
care about black lives
we know that all across america uh in in
major cities
uh black crime rate has gone up black
homicide has gone up black people are
dying
because of black lives matter activism
uh people burning down and looting black
neighborhoods taking away black
jobs uh so i i hate everything to do
with black lives matter
um and i have used my platform my voice
to speak out against what is ultimately
a big lie
um right this is all built upon the idea
that black americans are being gun
unarmed by a police officer we're just
peacefully you know do up
doing our business and a police officer
sees us and they come up to us and they
want to shoot us and they want to kill
us and that's a lie
uh if you are genuinely concerned about
black lives if i was going to be fearful
in america
i would be more afraid of a black person
a black male
a black perpetrator than i would be of a
white person or a white police officer
going by the statistics
we we kill our own people way faster
than
any other person i actually say this is
controversial if you are truly sincerely
a white supremacist
in america the best thing you could do
is do nothing and let let black america
tend to itself because what we do to
ourselves
right when when left tended left
unattended to ourselves
is way worse when you look at the
statistics and any than allowing any
other group to come in um and try to do
anything to us and that's including of
course police officers who are not
killing
black americans uh for no reason so in a
second i want to ask you about the
extent to which racism still shapes life
in america because it remains this key
issue in american politics and the stats
tend to be rather
split on all of this i'm gonna get your
answer on racism in america one second
first
i have life insurance i have life
insurance because i am a responsible
human being and i want to make sure that
my family is taken care of
if god forbid i plot if an anvil falls
on my head at least i know that my
family is not going to be
lacking in the money department you
should have life insurance too if you
got a family anybody who is dependent on
your income
with everything going on right now a lot
of people are asking whether you can
even buy life insurance the good news
yep and you can do it really easily and
quickly with policy genius
right now you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by using policy genius to
compare life insurance policies
when you're shopping for a policy that
could last for a decade or more the
savings really do start to add up
what is policy genius well it's an
insurance marketplace built and backed
by a team of industry experts here's how
it works step one you go to
policygenius.com
and then in minutes you can work out how
much coverage you need and compare
quotes from top insurers to find your
best price step two you apply
step three policy genius handles all the
rest policy genius works for you
not the insurance company so if you hit
any speed bumps during the application
process they'll take care of it they
even have policies that allow eligible
customers to skip the in-person medical
exam
and do it over the phone which is why
policy genius has a five-star rating
across over 1 600 reviews
on trustpilot and google so if you need
life insurance head on over to
policygenius.com
right now to get started you could say
1500 bucks or more a year by comparing
quotes on their marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and important to get it right
okay so
the main pitch it seems of the
democratic party these days that america
is systemically racist
according to the 6019 project america
was rooted in racism america's
a 400-year story of nothing but the
foundations of racism being carried out
in every aspect of american life
so how much do you think that racism is
actually an obstacle to
black americans living today not in 1960
when jim crow not not in 1860 when
slavery was a thing
but today in 2020 america it's not at
all an obstacle to black americans today
um it is just there's no systemic racism
there is no law there is nothing that
says that i can't do something as a
black person that you can do
um so it's completely completely false
what we're really talking about is the
fact that people want to absolve
themselves of personal responsibility
and we're being helped if there's
anything that's systemic in white in
america today it's white guilt
and that's the biggest problem that we
have in america today is white guilt
it's been institutionalized it's been
politicized
politicians white people feeling bad for
themselves and therefore allowing people
uh allowing black people and white
people alike you know
antifa black lives matter to run around
and act like toddlers
right so there's an emotional immaturity
that is happening black america and is
spawned
from the education system which shapes
you from the time that you are in
kindergarten to believe
that because you're black you can't in
america when you keep telling a child
over and over again they can't because
they won't right they will they will
believe to believe
begin to believe in their own futility
and um this is the thing that i try to
conquer
right i try to go out there and i try to
speak and i try to say the problem if
you want to talk about anything systemic
it's that white people keep allowing
this false narrative to be perpetuated
and won't allow black americans to get
up onto their own two feet
and you know and that really stems from
i would say the mid 1960s where
black america sort of took a shift away
from the peaceful civil rights into this
more
you know hardcore militant black civil
rights of burning down your
neighborhoods and looting and rioting
because they didn't want to take
uh steps to be personally responsible
what do you make of the argument
i know that you covered some in your
book blackout uh the the argument that
was made by
lbj and still made by democrats today
that one of the big problems is that
historic racism
is built into the system such that
people are starting from
behind the eight ball that if you look
at the broad history of the united
states the black americans were
discriminated against for the vast
majority of america's history really
only alleviated legally
in the 1960s and 1970s and even beyond
then there were informal structures of
racism
and therefore that black americans are
starting off inherently
behind sort of the the starting line lbj
suggested
for example that it would not be proper
to simply remove all barriers to entry
you're still leaving people who are so
far behind that they can never catch up
and that just wouldn't be appropriate to
say okay now you're free to live your
lives when they've already been
systematically deprived of resources
that other people have had in the united
states
look nobody will debate the fact that
black americans were oppressed in
america for a long time
the problem is that you're talking about
lbj's howard university speech where he
said
you know we need to fix this fair we
need to give black people full freedom
we're getting rid of jim crow great
great all of these things and then he
did the worst thing ever
which is he assigned white guilt to
everybody and said but but it's not
enough to just give them their freedoms
you know we all have to get involved and
we have to do this and we have to do
that um what i can say to you is that
there is no group that has ever lagged
behind another group that has gotten
ahead
with handouts you can you have to at
some point do the hard work
right so let's say i'm i've been
illiterate because i grew up in a black
america where i wasn't allowed to read
i'm not going to learn to read by you
pretending i can read
eventually i'm going to have to learn to
read myself and this is sort of when you
all of these programs that are meant to
instill equality which are fundamentally
racist in and of themselves right like
allowing more black people to get into
schools which hurts black america these
affirmative action practices which was
started by lbj in this initiative
for white people to feel guilty enough
to just allow what black people
um to be given accolades and
scholarships that they don't deserve
it is harmed black america over time
because at the end of the day you know
the information
or you don't you can do it or you cannot
and here's a great example
look at the areas in which black
americans actually excel in what are the
areas we sell in
sports right did lebron james become
lebron james because every time he
scored a basket we pretended it was four
points
of course of course he didn't get he did
it because he did the hard work he went
after school every day
whatever it was he practiced his game
and lebron james became lebron james
because he did the work and he put in
the work
so the areas that we excel in you know
disprove the idea that the areas that we
lag behind
we're going to get ahead by somehow just
being giving handouts we have to do the
work
there's a point shelby steele has made
specifically with regard to basketball
suggesting that
you don't say to a kid who's unable to
dribble well you know if we give you
this handout or that handout you're
going to learn to dribble we say okay
now you need to learn to dribble
right and that is the only way that
anybody gets ahead of any color or in
any point in american life
so how did you personally make the
transition you didn't always believe
this stuff
uh in fact when would you say that you
became more conservative on these issues
what's actually funny is that i've
always been conservative i just didn't
know
that i was a conservative and i think
this is what a lot of black americans
suffer from
um we're raised quite conservatively and
i was definitely raised staunchly
conservatively in my grandfather's
household
but i didn't care about politics i was
ignorant about politics so i went
through the public school system and if
you come out of the public school system
out the other side
and you actually learn if you actually
study you walk out you get your degree
and you know you know what republicans
are racist
conservatives are racist and at every
point that we've ever gotten ahead it's
because of
democrats i mean even lbj i mean it's
amazing they make it seem like he was
this wonderful president for
for black america because he signed the
civil rights act in 1964.
he was forced to sign in 1964. you know
he stepped in he became president
because jfk got
killed and there were massive riots all
around the entire time he was in senate
for 20 years he voted against every
initiative to help black americans he
was a staunch racist he used the n-word
all the time you know when he was in the
white house and yet they've rewritten
history and it's disappeared so we
learned that lbj was a hero
so i wasn't politically inclined at all
i had never voted um but if you had
asked me you stopped me on the street
and you said
you know are you a democrat republican i
would have said democrat and it would
have been because of the reasons that i
just listed
um so i started paying attention in
politics when donald trump came down the
escalator
and which is quite hilariously because i
thought this man should never be the
president united states ever right so i
don't care
where you were in america i mean i was
on your side with this like no not this
guy
i thought that he was just uh too
boisterous to new york and
also he was the guy who says you're
fired like too cultural to be the
president united states i didn't believe
that he was the right person for the job
especially coming off of obama the
smooth talker um but then something
weird started happening where this guy
who i thought
should not be the president united
states rather than saying he shouldn't
be the president united states because
he's not qualified
the media started saying he shouldn't be
the president of states because he's a
racist
a sexist a homophobe i'm thinking wait a
second
this guy has been loved you know in the
media they loved this guy i mean in
every hip-hop song i listened to growing
up they wanted to be like trump you
wound up at mar-a-lago he was a symbol
of status and of wealth
so i asked myself an important question
and that question was is it plausible
that black americans are now
being and racism is being used as a
theme to turn black americans into
single-issue voters
and the answer is yes and i started
researching and i fell in love with
thomas soule
i mean it really was a story of falling
in love with thomas soul and his books
and he knocked me into reality
and you really you really can't unsee it
you can't unsee it after you
once you learn the knowledge of how
we've been used as single-issue voters
you can't unsee it so republicans have
been struggling obviously for decades to
try and make inroads in the black
community
shockingly some of the polls show that
trump is actually making some inroads in
the black community which is a complete
obviously surprise
to many of the pollsters and to many in
the mainstream media
what do you think is the best way for
republicans to speak
to members of the black community
because it seems that they've tried a
bunch of different angles all of them
seem to fail
many of them seem to be very apologetic
in tone there's this feeling like okay
we have to make excuses for what we are
saying
it's always seemed to me that if you
talk to black people the same way you
talk to everybody else because black
people are like everybody else that
seems like the best way to do it but
right
but i think you have more expertise on
this than i do yeah how should
republicans talk to members of the black
community so i've noticed with
republicans is that they're suffering
from ptsd
you guys get called racist so much that
you're you're fearful right and i'm
saying you guys i'm kind of looping you
into all of this but
um they're fearful to say anything even
if it's true everyone kind of tiptoes
out i always describe it as like the
scene the wizard of oz and the munchkins
come out like
you know even though your instincts
you're like you know george floyd this
doesn't sound right
republicans will will wait and wait
until somebody else is at first because
you've been called racist for
absolutely nothing for years um and the
reason why trump was able to make
inroads is because he's rude
right and here's the thing black america
needed someone cultural he needed
someone who didn't care who wasn't going
to apologize he was going to say what he
meant and not apologize for it because
it was simply true
when he gave that infamous speech and
said black america what do you have to
lose and he listed all of these ways
that black american communities are
suffering
and the media calls him a racist he
never apologized for it he never said
i could have said that better or you
know i should have been more sensitive
he simply said it and he left it there
and that is actually that should be a
call to action for all republicans
don't apologize if it's true it's true
if you haven't been called racist yet in
2020 you haven't lived we've all been
i've been called racist you know i've
been called anti-black so i think that
that is the most important lesson is
just
be courageous because at the end of the
day silence is not winning us
what i always say about the right which
is really interesting is that the right
is playing by rules that were
established by the left
and the left is playing by no rules
right we we have to start fighting
um and and and i i worry that there's
not enough voices that are willing to
just simply say this
say the truth let it linger and not
worry about you know the names that
they're being called
so speaking of having the uh having the
courage to step into waters where angels
fear to tread
uh you obviously cut this video in the
aftermath of the george floyd death in
which he went through specifically his
criminal record
and you talked about not really the
situation surrounding george floyd's
death which now as it turns out new
details suggest it's a lot more complex
than the original narrative
you talked specifically about the
attempts to elevate george floyd
into a sort of moral paragon which
obviously is something that the the
culture has done that's what the media
have done
uh and you see this fairly routinely is
the attempt to suggest that that people
who at the very best until the moment
they were shot by police had led
difficult lives are in fact people who
ought to be emulated or
who are free of any moral stain we're
seeing more recently with jacob blake
who's being elevated into a loving
father of three as opposed to a person
who had an open warrant for both
domestic violence and sexual assault in
the third degree
and who resisted arrest so what prompted
you to make that statement and and why
do you think so many people in the media
have been willing to simply cover up the
reality of of whose
criminal suspects are in interactions
with the police
you know when i started looking into who
he was and i had no question he was
going to have a rap sheet i had no que i
mean i knew
obviously the police did not stop this
man for no reason um and i knew that it
couldn't have escalated that situation
unless he somehow was resisting arrest
despite having no knowledge of that
when i did look into him and i found his
rap sheet and i'm sitting here thinking
that they've elevated him
to such a level that they're burying him
in a gold casket like a gold casket dr
ben carson will not be born in a gold
cast larry larry elder will not be
buried in a gold casket
you know all of these condoleezza rice
will not be buried in a gold casket
um but this person who was spent nine
nine prison stands nine prison in jail
since which is remarkable actually if
there's any record guinness book of
rockets look at that nine
prison and jail spins before you turn 40
is actually the most impressive thing
he's ever done his entire life
um elevated and you have little black
kids that are wearing shirts
uh merle's being painted of him calling
him a hero
former vice president joe biden saying
that they're going to speak at his
funeral
this is crazy and it's indicative of
where we're at in black culture where
this is what we constantly do
we elevate people that should not be
elevated and we downgrade people that
should be elevated right so condoleezza
rice
uncle tom larry elder dr ben carson
stupid that's my favorite one
a literal neural surgeon is stupid right
um and
and this is a problem with black hole
trim and until we have the courage to go
into it and say this is wrong
you can disagree with whether or not
derrick chauvin should be on his on you
know
have been on his neck for that long and
disregard the fact that he was high on
fentanyl and high end methamphetamine in
his system at the time of the arrest
but you should also disagree with
elevating this person to the level of a
hero
and it i just felt it was weighing on on
me for days
just watching people spin this man into
a hero and i said i have to say
something because this is a lie
and and i don't care about the peer
pressure i don't care about you know you
you should just be quiet because let let
his family grief
a four-day funeral i mean none of us
we're never going to get that none of us
are going to get that
and we've lived our lives apparently a
lot more nobly than he did
so speaking of that number one why do
you think that everybody reacted the way
they did people were very very very
upset about all of this
and there is sort of an unspoken rule
that after somebody dies you sort of
let the let the dead be buried but
obviously you went
and you went after him on a character
level i mean you talked about who he was
as a character why do you think it was
important to do that and also why do you
think
it is that there's this phenomenon in
american life where certain people
are elevated even barack obama seems to
have been denigrated in the american
public mind since his presidency when he
was elected it was a historic moment now
the fact that he was elected twice as a
black president with an overwhelming
majority
is not in any way a proof that america
is not racist we just have to ignore
that happening we have to pretend that
it's extraordinarily historic that kamal
harris has now been selected as vp
candidate even though we just had a
black president five minutes ago right
right
you know i would say what the left has
realized is that race is sort of
represents an achilles heel in america
meaning that they know that they stroke
this one issue uh because they've done
such a good job of programming people to
believe that it's still ever present and
it's not it's just not
um that they can inspire riots they can
inspire protests and they can inspire
upheaval and that's what they want ahead
of an election cycle
uh somehow they're pinning all the stuff
on the back of conservatives it makes no
sense
uh you know and and you have
corporations that are you know
capitulating to this ridiculous
narrative
and it's just it just becomes a way for
them to seize control and can seize
power
um by reducing black americans to
emotional toddlers
and that's what we're seeing uh you know
we're seeing a a toddler response to
things
uh not waiting to get more information
just saying black versus white
and it's remarkable if you look at the
actual headlines right
we know that you're more likely as a
white person to be killed by a black
person the other way around but when a
black when a white person is killed by
a black person the headline doesn't
mention race right it's it's
five-year-old
got shot by a man in chicago but the
second that you can they can look at the
races and say oh look a white person did
something bad to a black person
the media just just completely gets in
on that and just race race race race
race race race
and again i think it's just a tool of
manipulation because if you can get
somebody to
react emotionally and not rationally you
can control them they're yours
um and i've always just tried to be the
person that says look pause reflect
think rationally and wait to get all the
details and and don't see yourself i i
certainly
don't see myself as black first i see
myself as american first i don't see
myself as a woman
first i see myself as an american first
um and and we just need to get black
america to a more emotionally mature
uh spot than they are and it's difficult
when i said you know as i said earlier
when you have systemic white guilt it's
very difficult to expect black americans
to react
uh rationally rather than emotionally so
in the aftermath of your george floyd
video famously dave chappelle went after
you in his in his comedy special and you
handled it with real
plum i mean you just sort of laughed it
off and points out he's a cultural
figure he can say whatever he wants
uh it can't be fun to be attacked by
dave chappelle in the way
that you were attacked by dave chappelle
maybe you can talk a little bit about
that and what exactly did chappelle get
wrong about george floyd
you know i i saw it and first off i
didn't actually find it to be funny
right but i do believe that humor is a
safe space and
and the bigger thing to i look at a
perspective of that i say they're
already silent and comedians i don't
want to be one of those people even
though i find this to be
you know denigrating degrading
disrespectful um i don't i don't really
think that
it's right for me to say to a comedian
you can't say what you want but there
was absolutely nothing funny about the
entire 20 minutes of his speech
um you know he didn't seem to be in an
emotionally good spot if i'm being
honest with you
um and i think that he just took the
bait on the media
i actually kind of thought which is
interesting if you watch dave
chappelle's old skit he's gone after the
left a lot
and he's been threatened to be cancelled
and they you know they have something
bad to say about because he tells the
truth
and i felt like he was just giving them
what they wanted um and attacked me and
i i had sort of the big girl perspective
that here is probably you know the most
well-renowned
uh well-renowned uh comedian uh at least
in america
probably abroad and my name is being sad
of his mouth so people who don't know me
are gonna look me up and they're gonna
see my views and some people are going
to be brought over to the side and
realize
okay what she said was not really that
big of a deal you know
she kind of told the truth and that's
kind of what i'm after i kind of try to
look at the big picture
um and not be so selfish and egotistical
when i like see somebody attack me just
you know it's meaningless
so in a second i want to ask you about
that perspective because one of the
themes that runs throughout your book
is this theme of anti-victimhood this
idea that you're not a victim you have
agency in your own life i want to ask
where that came from in your personal
life what's your sort of history
with that and and why victimhood is so
attractive to so many people on all
sides of the
and of all colors it's a really rich
political vein for people to mind we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's talk about your helix sleep
mattress let me tell you i don't get as
much sleep as i should i have small
children that means they wake me up at
all hours
of the night what does that mean it
means when i am on a mattress that
mattress had better be great
good news helix sleep made a mattress
just for me and helix sleep can make a
mattress just for you
helix sleep has a quiz it takes just two
minutes to complete and matches your
body type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you whether you're
a side sleeper a hot sleeper whether you
like a plush or from bed with helix
there is no more confusion no more
compromising helix sleep is rated the
number one mattress by gq and wired
magazine
cnn called it the most comfortable
mattress they've ever slept on
and at least cnn was telling the truth
that time just go to helixsleep.com
ben take their two minute sleep quiz and
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
for couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and field
preferences for each side they've got a
10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up from you if you don't love it
but you will my sleep quality matters a
lot to me and that's why i have a
personalized
mattress from helix right now helix is
offering up to 125 bucks off all
mattress orders for our listeners
get up to 125 bucks off at
helixsleep.com that's helixsleep.com for
up to 125 bucks off your mattress order
helixsleep.com
alrighty so one of the themes that you
focus in a lot in
on in in blackout is the the theme that
victimhood and speaking about victimhood
and believing yourself to be a victim is
actually extraordinarily crippling you
have some personal stories
about your sort of realization that
wallowing in victimhood was a terrible
idea and actually crippling for your
future maybe you can talk a little bit
about that
yeah so i mean people i don't know
people in the political sphere know this
but when i was in high school i went
through what was classified as a hate
crime
uh and i talked about that in the book
what happened uh you know who the
perpetrators were and how the media
sort of when i was in high school took a
narrative away from me because they were
just like this is perfect
we have a politician's son called her
the n-word uh
and uh we can stick a label of her as uh
you know as a victim
and this person um as a racist and very
young people involved 14 years old 14
years old being called a racist me being
called the victim
before i really decide on who i want to
be in life um and so i got to
you know experience what it's like what
is what does it feel like being a victim
what do you earn
um from being a victim we've all been
victimized i could mine your life and
tell you you've been a victim before
i've been a victim before various things
very you know it doesn't necessarily
need to be but it doesn't need to be
about racism about anything you can be a
victim
but what is it about staying a victim is
what the left is after right like being
this is like what the ultimate
achievement like this is it you've
achieved the elixir of life be a victim
that is so harmful and so cancerous to
people uh we are human beings are meant
to triumph we're meant to get over
things it actually makes you stronger no
matter what you go through
if you champion those experiences and
develop a good perspective about those
experiences you become a stronger
individual
when i accepted this victim narrative i
suffered with anorexia for four years i
was absolutely miserable i was a mean
person i wasn't happy right but when i
suddenly had my aha moment
and realized i was a child and a
narrative was taken from me not only
from me
but from these kids and people didn't
know what had happened they just loved
the race thing
um i i realized that wow this is this is
completely toxic and it transformed my
life
and it wasn't the way my grandparents
raised me they never raised me to see
myself as a victim
my grandfather grew up on a
sharecropping farm picking cotton and
laying out tobacco to dry when he was
five years old he's never once
complained never once told me i can't do
something because of the color of my
skin
i think it's insulting to his legacy for
me to live in this america
to run around saying that i'm a victim
so i really
really do credit you know my grandfather
and the experiences that he championed
my grandmother in the experiences that
she championed when there actually was
systemic oppressions against against
black americans uh for making me feel
too ashamed
to grab on to this victim narrative when
it comes to race my ancestors didn't
live through what they lived through
so i could run around and cry about
being black so you mentioned earlier
that one of your great intellectual
influences was thomas sowell many people
have asked me
if i could pick one person america to be
president who would it be i've always
said so
who are some of your other intellectual
influences people who really sort of
changed
how you think about these issues and
others yeah larry elder i know he's been
on the show he's become a mentor to me
um i
sometimes if i don't understand
something because i wasn't alive for it
and i'll be like what happened with this
case i pick up the phone and i call him
uh he's been wonderful uh shelby steele
uh
and and thomas told me my top three in
terms of uh black authors that have sort
of slapped me into reality but non-black
people
milton friedman right so it's not enough
when i first got into politics i had an
idea and an itch
right like you know something's not
right here but it's not enough to just
be somebody who has a feeling you can't
just keep going out there saying black
people don't have to be democrats you
need to do
the research why are you a conservative
right do you do
what what do you send on why do you
believe in free markets and capitalism
what is western where does western
civilization come from um so there have
been so many authors along the way that
i had to sort of go back and
learn something you know i had learned
all throughout public school
but it was a miseducation not an actual
education so i had to
you know spend years studying reading
books and
seeing everything that i had missed
about western civilization and what
makes it so great
you know great starting book i always
recommend people read is how the west
was won
by rodney stark it's a great book to
sort of just get you kind of grounded in
you know what what is western
civilization and why people pretending
to hate it
um and to make you feel prideful uh and
and
make you feel proud and i i think i am
so proud to be an american
i'm proud of the story of my ancestors
i'm proud that i did not have to live
through that
and i am challenging and inspiring other
black americans to realize that we are
if you are a black american living in
america today you are part of the most
privileged black americans that have
ever walked the face of the planet
and yet you are also a part of the
whiniest
the whiniest and the most upset black
black people that have ever walked faces
the planet and that's problematic
something's not right there
so let's let's talk a little bit one of
the critiques that's been made of your
take on black america so you've used
language before where you've suggested
that people need to get off the
ideological plantation for example
and there's been a critique that
basically says you know you talk a lot
about black agency
are you depriving people of agency when
you suggest they've been indoctrinated
by the educational system or when you
suggest
that that they have uh been sort of told
what to think
they've been lied to are you suggesting
that people aren't freely choosing
what it is that they've chosen
politically or do you really believe
that
it's it's really not a question of
agency it's a question of misinformation
yeah it's a question of misinformation
and people always get me wrong they
think that i say things to be theatrical
when i say the democratic plantation
and people go you shouldn't say that you
shouldn't liken it to slavery no
actually if you sit down and you study
the model
of american slavery and i say democrat
plantation because at the starting point
of civil war
all democrats had slaves uh there were
no republicans that held the slave
that uh owned a slave um and when you
look at the model of it right what was
what was necessary illiteracy
black americans are not allowed to learn
how to read look across america today
you can go into inner cities here in los
angeles you've got black americans
75 percent of black boys can't pass a
basic literacy exam
major cities like baltimore across five
schools they couldn't find a single
black child that was
proficient in in reading or writing so
we are actually seeing through the
education system pollution the dumbing
down
of all americans right but especially
black americans and when you dumb down
black americans that means that they
start to look they're getting their
education from culture
right and that's problematic uh father
absence huge issue we know you you
actually were the person that woke me up
on that i watched an old video of yours
on black lives matter where you talked
about
uh you know 23 single motherhood rate of
1960 74
um at the time you shot that i think
it's 77 as we're sitting here right now
um and and what was important to
maintaining slavery
uh making sure the family was broken
down they were constantly trading slaves
if you read frederick douglass's book
his autobiography
in the first chapter he talks about how
he felt nothing when his mother died uh
felt nothing when he was taken away from
his sisters because that was important
to maintaining the slave mentality
so in fact in my book i have a book on
slavery and i really spell out when i
say democrat plantations i mean it
it's been updated it's been modified but
we are very much still living on the
plantation
doing the work for democrats and getting
nothing back right voting for them in 93
margins uh is to me that's the form of
slavery we're doing the work for you
and we're getting nothing back our
communities don't get fixed our children
don't get brighter
um so i i'm a lot more thoughtful than
people give me credit for it's kind of
it sounds like a flamethrower
uh like i'm just like i'm just a
flamethrower but uh i've thought deeply
about these topics
and i believe what i say so let's talk
about some of the cultural influences
that you're speaking about so obviously
you know there's the culture of politics
which is very much based in race
politicians have an awful lot of hate to
make out of out of suggesting that
people are racist
kamala harris is is i think the greatest
example of this i have ever seen in
modern american politics literally
calling
joe biden a racist and then one year
later suggesting that she called them
racist because they're in the middle of
debate which is about as transparent
a move as i can possibly imagine so you
have the culture of politics you have
the culture of hollywood
in which movies are constantly
suggesting that black americans are
victims recently there was a movie on
netflix i was watching with my wife in
which there was
a literal speech by jamie foxx about how
america was built to keep black women
down
uh and uh and then there is the the
culture of of music and i want to go
through each one of these with you so in
terms of the cultural podcasts we've
gone through that a little bit
when you look at how hollywood addresses
race uh
what are the problems that you see there
because obviously this is mostly a bunch
of white executives who are attempting
to
uh to i think be sympathetic or
empathetic to what they think black
americans
believe or want to hear or feel what do
you think about hollywood's messages on
race
yeah well first and foremost the
democrats control hollywood you're not
allowed to be a conservative
a vocal conservative and still keep your
job right i mean if you're a vocal
conservative you come out and you say
something you're canceled you're gone
you're out of here
um and and to me it's become a huge
propaganda machine
and as i mentioned earlier when you have
black americans who are not
educated black americans like these
black boys and who can't pass a basic
literacy exam
well they're where are they getting
their information from that means
they're watching movies
other watching tv hollywood becomes the
teachers right and i think that the
democrats have understood this for a
very long time and one of the
biggest mistakes that conservatives made
was giving up the culture war
the culture war is so important because
so many people are not going to pick up
a book
but they are going to watch snl they're
going to watch an snl skate and they're
going to accept that to be some some
some truth uh you know this must be
what's going on because they're making
fun of conservatives on saturday night
live this must be what everybody thinks
because it's made it
and you know to the big screen so
everybody must be feeling this we all
agree on this
uh that to me is simple propaganda so
let's talk about the culture of music so
we have some agreements and we have some
disagreements on the culture of music
famously
so when it comes to the culture of of
music
that is consumed in the black community
obviously rap is at the top of the list
there's obviously a huge gap between the
high forms of art that have been created
by members of the black community and
the rap culture of today
i mean it's a pretty broad range between
nat king cole and louis armstrong and
duke ellington
and say cardi b who's now i guess
interviewing the former vice president
of the united states
um what what do you make of rap culture
cause you have sort of a split opinion
on
unwrapped culture a little bit like on
the one hand uh you seem to recognize
some of the downsides of the messages
being pervaded on the other hand you've
suggested that there are some sort of
differential messages in there that
might be useful
right so i mean there are definitely a
minority of rappers who are rapping
about things that are actually important
um and i i grew up listening to jay-z i
don't like jay-z anymore because of his
politics and i think he's being used and
he's become a puppet but
growing up listening to his music
actually uh did something differently
did something different for me when i
was uh you know a hopeless
uh impoverished person listening to his
music and he talked about how he made
his way out he wasn't talking about
you know killing a bunch of people he
was talking about business you know and
his black album he really talks about
how he would not allow industry to use
him how he understood what his worth was
these things were actually important
lessons
um about uh business and and and it came
in a lyrical form
and it was good right i would say kanye
west he's never really written about
like go out grab a gat and just kill
people
but unfortunately today that's the
majority of what what rap has become
right and and so and i completely agree
with your assessment about cardi b
um it is one of the biggest insults if
black americans are not insulted
by the fact that joe biden who has been
hiding in his basement um
you know for the entire year made an
appearance and came up because he was
going to do an interview with cardi b
do we do we have nothing better to offer
i mean this would be akin to donald
trump saying i'm going to give no
interviews but he came up and he decided
to give an interview
to justin bieber right i mean i wish i
actually justin bieber i'm sorry i know
you're a christian man i don't want to
put you in the same boat as cardi b
um but it would be absurd right white
america would go what what is this why
why are you being interviewed by justin
bieber
and it's because you're pandering right
you're pandering you look at cardi b's
instagram you see she has millions of
followers and you think okay
this is an illiterate person and if i if
i appeal to this illiterate person and
she does
okay like she literally did uh in the
middle of this interview
they think she's cool she's hip just by
sitting here and and taking this
interview black people vote for me it's
basically saying
black people you are stupid you are dumb
and you're so foolish i mean
do you think what if she just said in
the middle of the interview joe biden
can you name
one cardi b album you know jeremiah do
me a favor just one
cardi b lyric he couldn't do it of
course he's not because he's being
handled and they're saying black people
like this person this is what they're
into
and and so here you go talk to her same
thing with hillary clinton when she went
on the breakfast club
and she said she had hot sauce in her
bag right she didn't know what beyonce's
song about came from
wonderful handler said say this right
probably got the questions ahead of time
say this
say you keep hot sauce in your bag right
now beyonce's song is trending and it's
hot sauce in my bag swag
and she looked like a fish out of water
and said it it is demeaning it is
pandering it is ridiculous okay
and she asks pointedly ridiculous
questions i want lower taxes but i want
universal health care for all she had no
idea what she was doing
and yet both bernie sanders and joe
biden made the time to sit with her
because they believe black people are
stupid
and black people that thought yay that's
a win no it's not a win it shows you
that they still believe
that you are so stupid that they
couldn't find many of the
amazing intellectual black people that
we have in the world to sit down with
and ask them
tough questions an interview with
condoleezza rice right an interview with
larry elder
uh you know even if you want somebody
that's that is a democrat that's fine
there are way more intellectual black
democrats you could have sat down with
that you
you chose an illiterate rapper because
that's what she is she's illiterate well
i mean i would have paid money to hear
joe biden's rendition
of what else as a popular rap artist
myself
whose remix slaps significantly harder
than the original
i i can honestly say that joe biden's
rendition i would have paid good money
so i i need to ask you about the kanye
issue so uh famously he had a little bit
of a teddy ted on on twitter yeah when i
when kanye came out and he was uh
supporting president trump and i said
live by the kanye die by the kanye which
is mainly
saying you know kanye takes a lot of
positions on a lot of different issues
uh and you got a little bit upset about
that it seemed uh on twitter so
what do you think is the proper
relationship between celebrity and
politics because
i am a strict down the line i think that
celebrities have no place in politics
unless they actually know what they are
talking about on any sort of deep level
you know i i understand the impact of
celebrity i understand but but i object
to it
right but you have i think a more
nuanced version of that so what's your
view on celebrity and politics yeah you
know with kanye i think what i was upset
with was that so many people were just
dismissing him and calling him crazy and
it's it's just not fair i mean i think i
like kanye connie's
connie's a friend um and kanye is a
person that
is a billionaire and i don't i would not
take someone you know
to be like he's richer than both you and
i sitting here combined right i'm
assuming i don't know maybe you're a
billionaire
um and and people keep taking him
lightly and he it's been his entire life
kanye was not coming out telling people
how to vote he never said vote for this
person he never said do this he never
said listen to me follow me he simply
said i support the president
and i'm tired of people bullying me
telling me that i can't wear a mega hat
and that was
such an important message especially for
black americans
and maybe um maybe i was emotional in my
response because it is
it is so hard you try being a black
conservative a miss
black lives matter right and and go out
and say i support the president and you
will see how you how you get treated
right
uh you it's easy you get called racist
with us it's it there is a
it's ferocious they want you gone i mean
they will accuse you of anything they
want you gone you get death threats you
get all these horrible things and here's
a guy that's just saying
i'm no longer going to lie about who i
support not if you don't support him
you're a racist i mean we know his wife
is not a trump supporter despite the
fact that she works with them and i
thought this is this is productive it's
a good thing for someone to say
i'm comfortable saying that i'm black
and i'm a conservative in the cultural
realm especially because we know
most black americans have their eyes
fixed culturally that it just sent a
huge signal that it's okay
to break away from the from the hive
mentality um now if kanye was out there
saying i'd like to inform
policy uh because i'm kanye west i'd
like to go in i will now be conducting
the interviews
i want to sit down with candidates and
make sure that what they're doing is
great i would have said
i have a problem with that right because
that's ridiculous to assume that
that because you're uh you know a
cultural figure you somehow are now
smart enough to be asking political
questions just pointedly ridiculous
so that was the nuance he wasn't doing
anything um that i found to be harmful
he just was saying i support the
president
so i actually agree that i think that
it's actually a very important thing
that that kanye west put on a maga hat
and basically said you know what it's
fine i'm allowed to wear a mega hat yeah
and someone who's been called a jewish
nazi for being a republican right i
certainly understand the uh the
perspective of being inside a minority
group where it is considered verboten
uh to to be on a different side of the
political aisle so
i'm very glad that happened i mean
speaking of which you know you talk
about sort of policy influences one of
one of the areas in which
kanye and kim actually did have a policy
influences on criminal justice reform i
know that you're an advocate
also i believe of criminal justice
reform i was uh i had some difficulty
with with the criminal justice reform
bill that the
the trump administration pushed mainly
because i was not of the opinion the
criminal justice system
is inherently racist i think there's a
case to be made that we should cut back
on the drug war because i think that
there are a lot of people in jail for
for ridiculous
silly crimes right uh or crimes that at
least they were in jail for too long for
um but uh overall i'm not of the opinion
that this is that people are being
incarcerated for no reason or that grass
incarceration is a serious problem so
where are you on criminal justice reform
do you think that that is a in
an effective version of outreach to
black americans i think you can i i
don't think there's a dichotomy here i
think you can
believe in criminal justice reform
without you know subscribing to the idea
that black people are being put into
jail for no reason i don't i don't
believe
i believe both i do not believe that
black americans are being put into
prison for no reason
but i do believe that some of the
harsher sentencing that happened you
know when bill clinton became president
three strikes you're out even if it's
three small things three strikes you're
out were wrong
a lot of people were still serving
sentences because of that um so i think
you know uh it it's good to take a look
at the criminal system i don't think
it's great and i'm someone who grew up
with uncles
um that were in and out of prison um i i
know for a fact when you get a kid when
they're young and they're in the system
if you can help them get out like when
they leave they get fifty dollars in a
bus ticket
right uh what do you expect someone
who's been in prison for a year you have
the fifty dollars in a bus ticket to do
in their life right they usually go back
to crime because they have nothing
and so their way of trying to get ahead
is to steal to rob do these things
what i loved about what they were doing
was creating these transition to these
transition programs which were so
desperately needed because
you don't want somebody who's desperate
dropped back into your community
you want somebody who goes okay we're
gonna we're gonna help you find a job
we're gonna help you get on your two
feet and that that is what i loved and
supported about the programming i do not
at all believe
uh that black americans are being
targeted by the criminal justice system
at all i'm actually staunchly against
that
you know we we commit more crimes so let
i want to talk to you in a second about
some of the solutions that that are on
the table because it seems like so much
of our racial conversation is problem
focused
and never solution focused nobody ever
wants to talk about the solutions
because that might actually get awkward
so we'll talk we'll get awkward about
that in just one second
but first if you're a responsible human
being you should have a vpn you should
be protecting your data the fact is
there are tons of people out there who
want your data in fact not too long ago
over 100 million people had their
personal information stolen
in a major data breach social security
numbers contact details
credit scores and more all taken from
capital one customers and it's not just
capital one
equifax ebay uber playstation yahoo
they've all had leaked passwords credit
card info and bank numbers
belonging to billions of users and if
you think hackers only target large
companies
wrong which is why i use expressvpn to
safeguard my personal data
online i know the guys at expressvpn i
trust them to protect my data and if
that's good enough for me
should be good enough for you too
according to recent reports hackers can
make up to a thousand bucks from selling
somebody's personal information on the
dark web
making people like me and you easy
lucrative targets expressvpn
is an app for your computer and phone it
secures and encrypts your data so you
can have peace of mind every time you go
online
the app connects with just one click it
is lightning fast the best part
expressvpn
costs less than seven bucks a month
listen if a breach can happen to capital
one it can easily happen to an
individual
like you protect yourself with
expressvpn the number one vpn rated by
wired cnet the verge and countless
others
use my special link expressvpn.com right
now
arm yourself with an extra three months
of expressvpn for free
that's expressvpn.com for an extra three
months for free
okay so let's talk about the the
solutions versus problems orientation of
american politics when it comes to race
it seems fairly obvious at this point
that a huge number of politicians have
an awfully large stake in the racial
conversation so long as no solutions are
actually
promulgated so joe biden many democrats
they keep throwing out the phrase
systemic racism
specifically avoiding any sort of
specific definition if you say to them
what do you mean by systemic racism
they literally will not explain it
because systemic racism technically
means one of a couple things it could
mean theoretically that there's an
actual policy in place that is racist
that's illegal
it could theoretically mean that there
are racists in the united states which
is obviously true and will be true in
every society for all time
for past and future because human beings
are inherently sinful and flawed or it
could mean that
historic practices have effects today
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
you get to implement policies that
discriminate against one group in favor
of another group so
the third is inarguable that history
matters but that doesn't necessarily
create a solution it seems like any time
anybody pushes forward a solution
democrats particularly and members of
the media get very angry about the
solutions that are being
forwarded so to take a prime example
senator tim scott put forward an actual
police reform bill and it was
filibustered by democrats while he was
simultaneously called in uncle tom which
did trend during the rnc when when he
was speaking
so let's talk about some of the
solutions that you think should be on
the table
in the black community which means
actively labeling some of the problems
that the black community is experiencing
beyond sort of a meismatic systemic
racism right i mean i think the solution
is for black americans to fix the
problems within our own community
the solution is for white americans to
get out of the discussion uh because we
have become the authors of our own
problems
uh the culture you've talked about
culture so many times when i was growing
up my mom and my dad never checked to
see if i did my homework
wait it was not important for them to
make sure that i was doing my homework
now i naturally did i was good at school
so i liked it
but it wasn't necessary because our
culture was a bit different now when i
went to my best friend's house who
happened to be japanese her father
terrified me
when we got home my god after school
he's like kathy her name is kathy you
sit down at the table right now you do
your homework i mean he didn't even
he was like osana said she even brought
somebody home because homework was so
important
so there's a cultural difference this is
why nobody wants to talk about asians
because they're they're the ones that
are doing the best in this country right
and uh they're doing the best
financially asian americans are doing
the best in this country nobody talks
about them it's because their culture is
different
uh they value different things black
values have to shift
uh you want to talk about a single
single father a single motherhood rate
why there's no fathers in the homes well
it doesn't hap it's not good for us when
you have a a culture
and music which glorifies baby mama
right baby mama this this amazing thing
uh we have to get serious about
education we need to get stop
criminalizing black americans who want
to get ahead for example i was bullied
in middle school by other black people
because i spoke proper english
literally that was my crime i spoke
proper english so they would say you're
acting white
when you start to assign attributes that
are are considered
whiteness speaking proper english caring
about your schoolwork
these are things that the black black
america makes fun of black americans for
uh because they say well that means that
you're not you're you're not black
unless you're speaking in colloquialism
unless you're listening to to dirty rap
if you're listening you're not listening
to cardi b you don't know her music
um so i've seen this growing up this has
happened to me we have a culture problem
in black america i think the best way to
fix it is for everybody to stop debating
about it
is everyone stop the hand-holding and
let black americans get to work
well it is amazing how many white
americans seem to want to take control
of this particular
debate uh the entire anti-racist
contingent led by robin deangelo and her
white fragility crew
they've attempted to regain control of
racial issues in america essentially by
suggesting that black americans cannot
be expected to fix the system the white
americans are the only ones who can fix
the system since white americans created
the broken system
in the first place this call has been
taken up by a wide variety of political
figures who call for things like slavery
reparations from the american government
it was taken up by the national african
american museum of history and culture
who literally suggested in full-on white
supremacist fashion
that things like punctuality and and
delayed gratification were white
attributes
so what do you say to white people who
insist that
you know they are so woke that they know
better than somebody like candace owens
what the black community needs
i say you're a racist right i find that
to be a fundamentally racist concept i
mean
and i've had that attack if white people
that come to me and say you don't
understand you don't understand
i don't understand what it's like to be
black in america i've done it my entire
life i've never taken
one day off on being black never not
even an hour off i've done it my entire
life
um and and yet they they have they feel
they have the authority
that white guilt has given them the
authority to help me understand what
it's like to be black which is basically
saying
that unless i view myself as less than
them
i can't be black imagine that i'm saying
to them i view myself as your equal
and that bothers them that real that
really bothers them this idea that black
americans are suffering because of the
color of their skin i mean imagine a
world where people think malia and sasha
obama are suffering
like that's that's what they're
suppressing because the color of their
skin but malia and sasha obama should be
given handouts in life that they're
suffering
and they're all these horrible things
that they're going through because the
color of their skin no
that's not true are there privileges
that you can be afforded uh
uh if you're rich yeah that's sometimes
the call of your skin it's called
economic privilege
and we should all aspire to have
economic privilege right that's why i
like free markets that's why i like
capitalism we
should all aspire to work harder but
becomes impossible
uh when we have this white guilt
permeating throughout
every aspect of american culture and and
that is what i just i absolutely hate it
i
i want nothing to do with it we have to
start changing it we have to start
changing the conversation it starts with
white americans
getting out of the conversation so
getting white americans out of the
conversation what are the discussions of
race like within the black community
in terms of are there gradations and and
places of origin so the media have
decided for example
that black ought to be capitalized and
then from white ought not be capitalized
because the term black refers to
people of a common ethnicity and origin
despite the fact that people from
jamaica
are not the same as people from kenya
who are not the same as people from
south africa or zimbabwe
or from the united states this is all
one unified group people white people
however
are merely defined in opposition to
black americans you see some of this in
in the treatment of kamala harris
because there have been people like
thomas chatters and williams who have
pointed out she's not actually an
american descendant of slaves right
she's not descendant of american slaves
that she is half jamaican and she's half
indian and if you're going to look at
the demographics of indian americans
indian americans are actually the single
richest subgroup
in america right now and so it's
difficult to make the case that indian
americans are subject to
vicious brute racism what are the
discussions of of race like within the
black community or is it sort of
irrelevant within the black community
itself
it's incredibly immature you know and
and i will say that over and over again
it's incredibly immature and and because
they just
have become so comfortable with being a
victim because society has allowed it
you've allowed the toddler to throw the
tantrum so many times that this is the
way that they think is the method to get
what they want it's easy
being a victim is remarkably easy right
that's the easy path in life life is
hard
you know being responsible for yourself
waking up every day going to work
taking responsibility when you do
something wrong that's the harder path
saying you're a victim and when you fail
it's because of white people the white
boogie man that's that's very easy
and uh so amongst black americans it's
very hostile
uh when a black american like me ordains
a thing for themselves
and says i don't accept this narrative
it's very hostile it's angry but it
needs to happen
you know i did a speech at uh not howard
university another another one of the
hbcus
and when i tell you i stood up there for
three hours and just took it boo
yelling i mean just completely crazy
would never happen in auditorium full of
white people because
they'll be a a tiny bit more respectful
than they were being that day
but after the three hours of them just
brutalizing me um
at the end of it they all kind of came
up and said you know i want to take a
picture with you
and i respect you for standing your
ground let that happen let that dialogue
happen
amongst black americans let them
actually hear a black conservative
perspective it's hard
to hear a black conservative perspective
when black conservatives are routinely
drowned out
by white voices ironically right
ironically by these white voices
pooh-poohing and saying how hard it is
for us to be black
but it's not hard for us to be black
it's hard for us to be successful when
you keep telling us it's hard for us to
be black
so you are one of the founders of blexit
which was an attempt to
get more black americans to exit the
democratic party uh and you know
there have been similar attempts to get
jews to exit the democratic party of
what's
wild on success unfortunately so what
are the metrics that you're seeing in
the black community are you seeing a
change
in thinking inside the black community
in terms of voting in terms of how
people think about
politics do you see any difference
generationally and how people think
about the various parties
yes i mean i think for the first time
there has been a lot of chatter and a
lot of debate in black america about
politics in general um and i think it's
because of people
like me like larry eller who have sort
of laid out on the line
and just said this is what i believe i'm
not editing that you know in terms of
blexit we're in 20 states now
you know we have chapter leaders and
ambassadors all across the state that
are in the community actually having
these discussions and knocking on doors
um and i think you know at the height of
this sort of racial unrest there also is
racial conversation
and i will tell you when i got started i
had no black fans it was your uncle tom
you're a
uh your house negro and that has
completely transformed and i
i'm you know inundated with emails of
people thanking me and the number one
thing that they say which i find to be
incredible
is thank you for giving me my life back
right and that's an incredible statement
because i
i feel that and that's how i felt when i
opened my eyes after i finished
the first time in soul book i wanted to
just look at him and say thank you for
giving me my life back like now it's
okay i can go out
um and and i can be great i don't see
myself as less than
victimhood is a weight you're walking
around with the weight on your back and
and you don't realize from where you've
been carrying that weight until you let
it go
and now i feel that i can sprint in my
life and i can go and i can achieve
things i know i can
because i know that i'm not being
oppressed because of the color of my
skin you know that's what blexit offers
for
for our members all across the nation uh
and and and the reason why we did it was
to create an actual community
because i think when you're a black
conservative you can think you're alone
and we wanted them to just see you're
actually not alone
there are tons of us popping up all
across the state all across america and
i
i do credit donald trump uh with a lot
of that because
he just had the courage and the audacity
to say it and not apologize
president trump obviously president
trump a very controversial racial figure
a lot of people maintain the media
maintain constantly that the president
is a personal racist simultaneously they
claim that joe biden is a great unifier
on the issues of race you obviously met
with the president
a bunch of times uh you know president
trump that he's a man who says very
awkward and off-putting things on a
fairly regular basis on places like
twitter
uh what do you make of the accusations
that he is racist it's so ridiculous
it is so ridiculous to call it call him
racist i'll tell you the only color that
our president sees is green and he's
been that way his entire life you know
the man likes money he likes success and
he likes winning
and i see nothing wrong with that he's
in the right place he's in america right
that shouldn't be controversial um and
and i
i admire his courage i you know agree
with the assessment people say all the
time i wish he would stop tweeting he's
not eloquent
we needed that you know we were dying
conservatives were dying because of
political correctness we needed the
exact opposite
of political correctness to have this
opportunity this this uh small window
opportunity to get ahead and get out in
front and i think we've done that and i
think conservatives have seized that
this is the first time i think that we
have seen so many conservative figures
uh find success um and people don't
realize that that is attached to
donald trump not backing down not
apology not apologizing it's giving more
people the same kind of a spine
um do we need a president donald trump
type character forever no
uh you know i mean i think after eight
years people say i'd like something a
little bit more calm
and that's fine but we needed him right
now he came at just the right time
so i'm a huge fan of him he's been
amazing to me he's been amazing to my
family
and i know i support him in every single
regard i think he is he's the man for
the job
right now and so meanwhile joe biden of
course has been cast alternatively as
the foil
to kamal harris who's trying to keep her
from a little black girl like her from
going to an integrated public school
and then simultaneously the lightbringer
when it comes to all racial issues who
can unify
the country so what do you make of joe
biden on the issue of race um to be
honest with you i don't know where he's
i think
uh he is mentally deteriorating um i
think
obviously if you look at his senate
record he was not he was not the biggest
supporter
of black issues he liked segregation all
that is true i don't think he knows
where he is right now
i find it actually if you want to be
insulted by something it should be that
despite the fact i disagree with uh
camel harris and virtually every policy
she has she is competent she's there
right
uh the fact that she ran against him and
lost and now is being
now as his vp uh it's interesting uh
because i genuinely think that he is
being hidden right now
because he's got some issues he's
mentally deteriorating he doesn't know
where he is and half the time he's
saying he's running for the senate
so he's not he's not a strong candidate
there she just doesn't have the it
factor when i say the if factor
so about being conservative donald trump
has this it factor about him
barack obama had knit factor bill
clinton hasn't it factored right whether
you light love over here these people
had an id factor
and they have an incredibly weak
candidate right now i don't know what
his policies are i genuinely
uh said they said this morning if you
walked up to a biden supporter and you
said tell me why you're supporting biden
and don't mention donald trump what
would they say
nothing i mean the entire dnc literally
was that just donald trump is a bad very
bad orange man who's orange and bad
and maybe hitler so maybe hitler
so uh so who do you think wins i mean
right now the polls show that biden is
up
pretty heavily uh they seem to be
narrowing a fair bit uh i think in large
part due to the fact that the democrats
have decided to
tut the the unrest in most of america's
cities and pretend pretending none of
that is happening
uh who do you think ends up winning the
election trump wins and i think it's
going to be by a lot
unless mail-in voting happens mail-in
voting makes me very nervous
um it's just something you can't get a
handle on but if if the election goes
forward and we can vote in person donald
trump is going to win
i think it's going to be my landslide so
putting aside some of the formal
politics one of the things that
frightens me most
uh is the way that corporate america has
embraced some of the victim mentality
uh you've seen it in virtually every
major literally every day i receive
emails from somebody at a major
corporation
who's being brow beaten to support the
black lives matter agenda no matter how
radical
uh we saw just this week that the nba
declared that they were going to cancel
games in protest it seems like corporate
america has taken it upon themselves to
mimic all of the most radical sentiments
where do you think that's coming from
and do you think that there's a future
for a unified country when even the most
apolitical aspects of american society
are being politicized to this extent
yeah you know i would say corporate
america is completely spineless
and we have seen in the rare examples
where somebody actually stands up for
their company and says i'm not going to
do that they win
because one thing about the left is they
have add right so they're super angry
about something one day but then they
forget why they're angry because they
need to be angry about something else
the next day
um and we saw that with i believe it was
soul cycle this is the owner of
soulcycle hosted dinner with trump and
then you had chrissy teigen
i'm canceling my soul cycle uh
membership which was one of the most
out of touch privilege four hundred
dollar a month membership most people
don't have that they can't join you on
it
on this uh this boycott um but she did
that and then you know what she was
angry about something else two days ago
and nothing happened to soul cycle
and they need to realize that that that
is what the left is they want to see
if you will capitulate if you will do
what they tell you to do if you will get
on your knees and if you do it
you they forever own you that's the
thing they forever own you which is why
i am so hesitant to ever apologize
for things because all they want to do
is expose a weak spot and once they have
you they have you for good
so don't apologize for things that you
know are ridiculous uh for for being a
company and saying oh well they have
10 white executives and only one black
executive and suddenly you're you're
revamping your entire company uh you
know because black lives matter says so
posting the black square is one of the
most meaningless things that we've ever
seen
uh done all across america but they all
did it racism
i always have a peaceful day of no
leftists on instagram i was like please
let's do let's do this please guys
please be quiet
um but uh yeah you know it's pointedly
ridiculous and
you they can't keep it up that's the
thing it's like it it
kind of goes against free markets and
capitalism because we're also competing
globally
if you really are hiring people on the
basis of whether of their anatomy
whether they're
you know a woman or a man and not based
off of their skill set and the merit
um uh it doesn't work long term you just
can't it doesn't work long term this guy
was really dumb
uh but you know he was spanish and we
need to hit the spanish box so uh
we this is why we hire him it doesn't
work um so it falls apart and i think
that eventually
they will realize that they've made a
dangerous dangerous mistake it's a
slippery slope
and they're going to lose so you
mentioned privilege there when you talk
about chrissy teigen
and in your book you you say at one
point that liberalism is a system of
remarkable
privilege what do you mean by that when
you say that liberalism this kind of
liberals that we're seeing today can
only happen
in a sign when we're all privileged
right how privileged do you have to be
to be able to debate bathroom signs
like to be able to say this is my issue
i want them stripped
saying either man or woman i need the
sign to say any gender can go here
i mean do you think during the great
depression that could have been a thing
like you really think like when people
are jumping out of buildings losing
losing all of their money and everything
like that would have been a thing if
somebody had said at that time
listen i know that we're all really poor
we don't have nowhere to live but these
bathroom signs right
like because we're doing this in the end
these these fights are getting more and
more ridiculous these
are more ridiculous it really is a sign
a symptom of just a remarkably
privileged society conservatism is about
sense and sensibility
everybody is a conservative in times of
hardship right you save your money
you work hard you're desperate to get a
job you'll do anything for the job and
and
and that is what conservative is all
about it's about it's about grits about
determination
um and and that is sort of the picture
that our that our our founding fathers
foresaw when they created this country
and then when we are privileged and
everything works because of a
conservative system
you end up with privilege you end up
with liberalism you end up with leftism
unleashed and that's what we're seeing
today
these kids are brats i mean call it what
it is half the time when you see these
kids getting arrested i think they
should arrest the parents to who raised
this
who did this how did you turn out being
a kid that put on a black mask and threw
in a molotov cocktails into somebody's
business
right and and and that that really is
it's a symptom of the
baby boomer generation which i get into
in my in my book uh something that
shelby steele helped me understand
um because they were the first
generation that won the argument against
their parents because the media told
them
everything your parents did was wrong
because they were the jim crow
generation and
now you are right and you have the
agency and you know everything
um and uh it's something that we need to
sort of just focus on and get people to
realize that
they're bratty they're spoiled they're
over privileged and that's really what's
happening in america today
so you mentioned social media there and
the black square posting and all of the
sort of virtue signaling that happens on
social media
all the viciousness you know twitter
obviously is a place where to to dunk
and be dunked upon is is the way that
i've put it
do you what do you think of social media
you're obviously a very
avid and uh an excellent user of social
media to promulgate your points
what do you think of of social media do
you think it's been bad for the country
and
is there any way to use it positively
social media has been terrible for the
country i mean it's like
people are killing brain cells i mean i
sometimes i'm i cannot stand
being on instagram it's just like girls
with their butts i mean it's just it's
ridiculous because let's be honest
it's it's made everybody a bit dumber um
but it's necessary evil
this is where the left is fighting and i
have to say that if it wasn't for social
media conservatives wouldn't be where we
are
uh we we're winning there and the left
knows it right when it was just the tvs
they were winning they were dominant
everything was left this leftist
now you get people like brian selter who
are uncomfortable about the fact that
you have more followers than him i have
more followers than him
you know because it downgrades when he
gets up there and says racism is what's
happening everywhere and it's because of
we're bad we're white
and you and i can counter that narrative
in one tweet you and i when one tweet
can dwarf
all of cnn's viewership that makes them
uncomfortable and we need that so it's
actually in in a weird way
it's paradoxical it's necessary it's
evil it was necessary evil and it's
actually a space that conservatives are
winning in so let's talk about some of
the work you've been doing over at
prageru so you moved over from turning
point
usa to prager university what a couple
of years ago yeah
uh and prageru obviously sort of a
sister company for daily wire we've
worked very heavily with them
in the past so what prompted you to to
decide to move over to prageru which was
a real shift in what you were doing
yeah so you know one of the things about
turning point is it's it's such an
important battle to say we're going to
fight and win college campuses
the first thing is i got into this
because i wanted to change black hearts
and black minds
um can't really do that at on college
campuses because unfortunately most
black americans don't make it to college
campuses
um so i felt like you know charlie and i
were sort of doing the same routine over
and over again but was i actually doing
what i set out to do
the second thing is that because turning
point is a company that is focused on
college campuses everybody that works
there is fresh out of college
um and i am a controversial person i say
what i want to say
and it isn't fair when i say like when
the whole world collapsed and i said i
don't support the metoo movement i was
the first person who came out and said
not doing this this is wrong and when
everybody has a meltdown about it i mean
charlie was inundated with emails from
people you know at turning point girls
that are on campus being like
i can't believe candace supports rape
like how you have to and i'm like
charlie i can't i mean i
this is you know they're young i get
that but i'm obviously not saying i
support rape by saying that i don't
support the metoo movement
uh so i kind of got too big in a way
where i sort of felt like this isn't
fair
for charlie to have to keep explaining
to these younger people who are just
kind of
experimenting with conservatism uh and
prageru is obviously
when i say a more mature organization i
mean that no they don't have a bunch of
20 year olds that work there and they're
not they're not a student organization
they're making five-minute videos that
are very focused and
they sort of understand a bit better the
battle that we're in and they stand by i
mean
prageru i'm getting accused of being
literally hitler this is a jewish
organization and they stand
by it and it's just easier it's just
it's just a lot easier and i wanted to
be put in long form
you know and you've done the college
campuses it's fun ben shapiro
owns that you know kenneth owens owns
this uh but i was kind of looking for a
bit more a longer dialogue to have
people on my show
and to learn i mean i have people on my
shoulder much smarter than me and i get
to sit down there and i i get to i get
to sit there and i get to learn in an
hour
uh soak up all of larry elder soak up
dennis prager
um and so i was just sort of ready for
the next step
so how does your career match up to what
you thought it was going to be 15 years
ago
gosh it is crazy it has been
a blessing and in every single regard i
thank god for the platform that i have
of course there are moments
where you you know i think and i'm sure
you understand this when you go through
a firestorm or you're getting death
threats the responsibility that you feel
to your family
uh that's the hardest part um and i
never thought i would be here
and that is why when people say to me
candice run for president or candace do
this
i no longer plan i just do what i'm good
at uh and
uh you know i i i think i work really
hard i think i
i didn't want to be one of those people
uh that's super flippant
you know one of those i hate to say this
but conservative girls with a gun in
their
a gun in their shorts like i'm
conservative
i was like you know i want to i want to
learn i want to grow
i want to be here for a long time i want
to look back and say she
became a larry elder or thomas soule um
so i've been doing a lot of studying and
i don't know where it's going to go
and who knows maybe it all ends tomorrow
we're all but i think i've been canceled
so many times and i can't be canceled
anymore
um so you know just it's just god god
has a plan for everybody
and it's his plan is never for anyone to
be a victim and i hope that my life
teaches other people
that so in a second i want to ask you a
few more questions a few final questions
about the future of the republican party
and where you think the republican party
is going to go and some personal
questions
but if you want to hear the answers to
all of those
fascinating questions then you actually
have to be a daily wire member head on
over to dailywire.com click subscribe
you can hear the rest of our
conversation over there well candice
owens thanks so much for stopping by be
sure to grab a copy of candace's brand
new book blackout
candace thanks again this is awesome
thank you that was different
[Laughter]
awesome
[Music]
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens and
our assistant director is pavel wydowski
associate producer nick sheehan our
guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nichol audio is mixed
by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by nika geneva title
graphics are by cynthia angulo
the ben shapiro show sunday special is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2020.